la douche choquée par les propos de
Thierry Ardisson mes amis c'est
pipolémique cette semaine Thierry
Ardisson a donné une interview à la
profité pour régler ses comptes lorsque
le journaliste lui a demandé ce qu'il
pensait du ton des tocs de la télévision
d'aujourd'hui l'homme en noir celache
vous avez comme d'habitude on remarque
moi je suis fan de Thierry Ardisson
maintenant vous dites ce que vous voulez
moi je suis fan de Thierry il dévoile
avoir tout faire des réseaux sociaux des
deux ans où il était sur C8 on va voir
derrière ce qu'il avait dit dès que tu
disais un truc qui avait 50000 tweets
ben oui c'est comme ça à l'échelle même
si elles ne veulent pas le reconnaître
elles sont en alerte quand il y a 50000
tweets il dit que finalement quelque
part il y a plus d'importance les
chaînes donne encore plus d'importance
au tweet que la réalité de l'émission ou
de la qualité ou des téléspectateurs
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez qui veut
réagir Déborah déjà je trouve ça bizarre
qu'un homme avec une telle carrière
c'est un homme comme Thierry Ardisson
prête autant d'importance au tweet et
aux gens qui tweet non si c'est bizarre
arrête pas la télé parce que il y a
quatre clampants là qui ont tweeté sur
ton émission et qui oh je peux pas
blairer de céréales
qui n'ont rien à [__] rien d'autre à
[__] quand vous voyez des tweets
tweeter c'est anonyme alors ça c'est moi
l'anonymat ça m'agace on peut dire ce
qu'on veut trop pour moi dans ce dont
l'action
parce que c'est vrai que c'est ça nous
énerve tous quand on a des des
versements de haine chacun a son niveau
sur nos comptes twitter etc par des gens
qui ont pas fait grand chose de leur vie
qui passe leur journée à dire à quel
point tu as une tête de trou du cul
voilà je peux comprendre le seul truc
qui pour moi
ça aurait pu dire des gens il est pas
obligé de dire les chômeurs parce qu'il
y a pas que des chômeurs qui twittent
c'est vrai il y a des chômeurs
on est d'accord
mais c'est vrai que parfois quand tu es
de mauvaise humeur moi en général je
clique pas et je ne tuerai plus
d'ailleurs mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
parfois les mauvaises humeur tu vois tu
en prends plein la tronche pendant trois
semaines tu réagis
c'est fini alors
on peut mettre demain sur la table parce
que je sais pas ce que tu fais avec
l'autre c'est pénible
je suis entièrement d'accord avec ce que
dit Laurent c'est
une émission est regarder des fois par
un million 700000 de millions et toutes
deux millions cinq comme l'émission de
Cyril et on focalise sur les 25000
haineux qui écrivent mais c'est humain
effectivement on ne voit plus que ça
c'est le petit bout de la lorgnette et
c'est vrai que ça fait mal mais lui il
arrête les réseaux il arrête pas la télé
critique petite phrase supplémentaire
laissez penser que les chaînes donne
plus d'importance et notamment c'est
vite autrui c'est pas vrai que hôtesse
c'est une connerie
ici qui vous lisez tout ce qu'on vit sur
moi
même si on peut dire ça me touche pas je
m'en fous et tout quand tu te fais
insulter une fois deux fois trois fois
moi j'ai j'ai eu quelques moments un peu
compliqué quand j'étais journaliste
sportive vous ça a été un petit peu dur
ça te touche c'est impossible de passer
au travers c'est impossible de rester
complètement de marbre on est des
humains voilà ceux qui disent je m'en
fous non c'est pas vrai
bien sûr parce que quand tu as un
million cinq de personnes qui sont
visiblement contentes t'écouter la télé
quand on commente le patinage avec
Nelson et que tu as un tweet ou un
message haineux tu crois déjà tu
comprends pas et c'est celui-là que tu
retiens pas faire plaisir à tout le
monde ça c'est sûr mais là quand on
t'insulte alors que tu as rien demandé
tu as juste essayé de faire un peu
d'humour voilà c'est un peu tu réponds
pas je réponds pas ça dépend jusqu'où ça
va en fait mais vous récoltez tout ce
que vous avez semé vous essayez tous
d'avoir le maximum de followers
la masse de followers il y a des gens
qui me critiquent les boulets dire que
des compliments
tu as pas besoin d'être le follower de
quelqu'un mais dans ou un chroniqueur ou
un animateur ou qui que ce soit va
peut-être dire la petite phrase qui va
buzzer forcément quand tu fais ça tu
tends le bâton pour te faire battre tu
sais très bien que ça va faire réagir et
si ça fait réagir toi ça te fera plaisir
et ça il dit ça surtout par rapport à sa
dernière émission qui a été un flop
total où il interviewait des morts Jean
Gabin Dalida ça va pas du tout marché il
s'est fait allumer sur les réseaux mais
alors d'une avec d'une violence inouïe
pour le coup parce que les gens là-bas
c'est pas encore hein je crois
mais elle avait
été anne avait vu en extrême les gens
voulaient même pas le voir enfin ça a
été très violent donc je peux comprendre
mais moi ce qui m'embête c'est que le
mot chômeur il le présente comme une
insulte c'est à dire de la façon dont il
le dit un chômeur était oui mais non
c'est presque le mot Wilson est une
insulte c'est ce qu'on a dit
effectivement c'est le mot qui nous
choque un chômeur n'a rien à [__]
aussi donc je pense qu'on peut aussi lui
présenter tout un tas de chômeurs qui
n'ont pas rien à [__] c'est pas vrai
chômeur il a pas choisi d'être au
chômage forcément et il a pas forcément
t'insulte sur Twitter ça doit t'arriver
non je réponds pas moi la problématique
c'est que j'ai pas le niveau de
notoriété etc qui fait que on m'insulte
pas trop sur mon physique parce que
c'est trop facile mais en revanche dès
que je prends des positions notamment à
TPMP beaucoup pour les campagnes
présidentielles par exemple ici sur
l'affaire lou Pernaut par exemple
mais je cherche pas je discute puisque
je pense ça nous permet
ouais la mer me retourne dessus donc tu
as tous les followers de Nathalie par
définition qui vont à la calèche knikov
donc à Maurice j'ai des trucs qui sont
tellement insultants et tellement alors
tu es très honnête Laurent mais tu es
réconcilié maintenant ça y est c'est
fini avec Nathalie mais j'ai jamais été
fâché elle a l'âge de ma fille on parle
enfin non non mais bien sûr oui mais de
quoi on parle aussi je vais pas me
fâcher qu'une fille de 19 ans et
sympathique comme tout pareil donc j'ai
zéro souci c'est juste que les gens qui
nous écoutent ont l'impression que j'ai
agressé cette jeune fille et
certainement des gens qui me défendent
vont chez elles dire tu es vulgaire
Laurent Fontaine a fait plein de trucs
toi et du tout j'imagine qu'elle a la
même chose voilà ça fait partie du jeu
on le sait moi je suis pas trop là
dedans parce que j'ai pas la puissance
tu as raison de certains ici tu as
raison
d'utiliser plutôt le mot branleur que
chômeur voilà mais oui
parce que leur vie à tweeté
on peut dire on peut dire ce qu'on veut
c'est la liberté de chacun et évidemment
on s'expose donc on a des risques etc
mais pas il faut lever l'anonymat c'est
l'anonymat qui me gêne tu vois si on te
dit en face bon Bernard Montiel il vient
te tenter de connard mais là on sait au
moins qui sait tu vois alors que les
gens caché sous des pseudos balance des
horreurs excusez-moi c'est trop facile
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord avec
vous sur l'anonymat quand ça va trop
loin mais en vérité les petites phrases
qu'on se prend régulièrement si ça
change quoi que ça doit être critère
quand même vous expliquerez